okay guys president's about to take off
for Arizona before he did took a few
questions want to go to that right now
Peter Ducey first question on the border
let's watch
going on they're going to invest
billions of dollars in a new Enterprise
no we don't yet I'm running that down I
got to reach the point
I disagree
Georgia
[Applause]
oh okay there you have it so On the
Border he said the reason he's not going
is because there's more important things
to do he is going down there to talk
about a 40 billion dollar investment in
a chip manufacturing plant in Arizona
however you can as he has said many
times you can go wherever he wants and
if he thinks it's important he will go
and if he doesn't go then it's not a
priority the last question that I
couldn't hear it was something about the
Defense of Marriage Act we'll see if we
can get a more clear answer on that and
bring it to you I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis